we have a voicemail number on the show
that number is two one nine to david p
and the voicemail line is made possible
by our friends over at linguist who make
it possible to learn a foreign language
incredibly fast with their spaced
repetition ai algorithm I have been
making massive progress in improving my
French using linguist you can try it for
free with no credit card at linguist
dot-com slash Pakman that's Ling vist
with a V comm slash Pakman
okay here's today's voicemail making a
inquiry about tribalism and political
labels hi David my name is Daniel out of
Houston I had a question about how you
label yourself as a leftist I had a
thought recently that perhaps calling
anyone as any sort of tribal label might
be disrupt disrupt 'iv and destructive
towards public discourse so how do you
feel about people self identifying
without any label just say I like to
watch the news I like to pay attention
I'm not sure what I am but we get your
thought how we going see here's the
thing I I agreed that there is a
discourse destroying effect of people
attaching themselves to tribal political
labels but the reality is that we need
some labels let me give you an example
when I say to someone they say what do
you do at a cocktail party I say I host
the political talk show they say oh
what's the bent of the show it's not
really practical for me to say well it's
a show focused on media literacy that is
pro-choice Pro LGBTQ rights against
supply-side economics you need to have
some kind of shorthand to serve as a way
to start conversations without needing
an hour introduction to what one's
politics are so I recognize the
good-faith nature of what you're trying
to point out and I don't disagree with
you that political
labels reinforce tribalism in in many
ways and in many contexts but to say
that we should not identify with any
labels at all anymore
I actually think would make it it would
it would be a type of sort of cartoonish
ideal fantasy that would actually
prevent us from even engaging in a lot
of the conversations that we need to
have so I understand what you're saying
but I think there's a sort of practical
element to it that we can't ignore we've
got a great bonus show for you today
become a member become a patron to get
instant access to the bonus show I'll
speak to you that in just a couple of
minutes